[Music]
so let's just go ahead and get a look at
what this final product is going to look
like um so on
like an x by x grid so whatever you want
it to be you have a little snake moving
around
there's a snack is what i want to call
it that shows up and as you collect it
it increases the length of the tail and
then obviously if you run into yourself
and i just did that by clicking the back
key while i was going forward
it gives you a little error message here
says you ran into your tail um your
length was nine
dot dot dot whatever um and then you can
continue and
play as long as you want um anyways what
i'm going to be doing in here is i'm
going to be coding everything object
orientated
i know that there's a much faster and
easier way to do this
but it doesn't really teach you that
much this way you're going to learn a
bit about objects about classes
how we can kind of work with them and
you'll see like how the flow of my
program goes and you should learn
quite a bit especially if you're
somewhat a beginner programmer
what we're going to be using to make
this is module called pygame
if you don't know about pi game and you
want to learn about it before you do
this i would recommend that
all right so let's start coding so
pretty much what i've done is
i've just set up the flow of the program
all the classes and the function just to
remind myself what i need to write
and while i'm talking here it's probably
a good idea if you guys copy this down
so what we're gonna have is we're gonna
have two main objects we're gonna have a
cube object and a snake object and our
snake object is going to contain
cube objects if that makes sense so each
one of those little red
i don't know squares that was moving
around is a cube object and the whole
thing is our snake object
we're going to have a few functions here
draw grid redraw window
random snack message box and main
so let's get started with our main
function here and this is what's going
to be our main loop
so essentially what i need for the main
loop to start is we need to make a
surface so in high game to do this we do
win equals pi game dot display
dot set underscore mode and then i'm
going to set it um
let's see here what do i want the height
to be let's say width
and height like this oops
bad spelling and i'm just going to make
a variable here called width equals
height equals and we'll just set this to
500 by
what i have 500 like so now we need
another variable i'm going to set this
as rows uh i can delete this down here
it's going to do something but i'll do
that later
um and this is how many rows you're
going to have or rows or columns
whatever you can set this to whatever
you want just make sure it divides 500
evenly otherwise you're going to have
like weird looking
rows if you know what i mean so i'm just
going to set mine to 20 that's what i'm
using in the other one but if you want
to make it harder set it to something
like 10
and there won't be as much room for the
snake to move around and the games will
go faster
pretty well okay next what we need to do
is we need to set up a snake object
so i know that uh we haven't even
created like anything in the snake
class yet but i'm just gonna do s equals
snake and
i'm just gonna give it a position so in
this case
we want to or a color sorry
which is going to be red because red
green blue 255 for red and then i'm
going to give it a position we're going
to start in the middle so i'm going to
start at 10
10. um now let's move into our main loop
so i'm just going to say
wow flag create my variable up here flag
equals true and then we're just going to
start by doing a
pi game tick so pi game dot time dot
delay
50 like so and that's just going to
delay us uh
i want to say like 0.5 or 50
milliseconds
every time so that our program doesn't
run too fast i'm also just going to
create this clock.tick i'm going to put
that at 10
and what i'm going to do is i'm going to
create a clock object up here
um and this is a built-in thing in pie
game and what this is going to do is
explain in just one second once i finish
typing it pie game dot
clock i believe it is oops dot time
dot clock like so so what this clock
dot tick is actually going to do is it's
going to make sure that our game doesn't
run at more than 10 frames per second
um so that would mean essentially that
our snake would be able to move
like 10 blocks in one second and again
we don't want it to be that fast
so that's why we're also delaying um by
like a few milliseconds here if you put
this too
low um then again it's going to move too
low you can play around with the speed
this is kind of what i found
was the best speed um and it may vary
depending on what machine you're on
it shouldn't it might so you might want
to just change these numbers um
again the lower this goes is the faster
it's going to be and the lower this one
goes is
the slower it's going to be so they're
kind of inversely proportional like that
all right um next what are we going to
do here
i'm just going to call redraw
window and i butcher that so bad oops
redraw window like so i'm just going to
give it a surface which is in this case
going to be
win that we've created up here and for
now that's all i'm going to put
in my main loop here and we'll move more
into that once i start coding some
other stuff okay so now that we have our
redraw window being called here
i'm going to go and i'm going to start
coding our redraw window
so what this is essentially going to do
is we first need to update the display
so pygame.display
dot update like so and we also need to
um draw the grid so we're simply going
to draw a grid
we're going to pass it that same surface
that we were given um
and move on from that we're also going
to fill the screen so
when dot fill in this case i'm just
going to use black so it's zero zero
zero
um and there we are that's all we need
to do right now but essentially we're
also gonna need to draw the snake
uh we're gonna need to draw a few other
things on the screen uh that
we'll get to later okay so draw grid
let's move into this one now
uh what we need to do here is a set like
draw a grid which is
pretty easy to do um so what we do is we
we're given rows and surface so it's
probably a good idea
if i actually passed in the rows and
surface so i'm just going to global them
here so that
i can reference them i think this is
going to work we'll do global
rows and width like that
and here we also need to make these
global just because i don't want to pass
them in every time i draw a grid
we're just going to say width uh oops
androids and this height variable is
actually not necessary
because we are just going to draw a
square
um like a square surface every time
so we can just make this the same we
don't need two variables for width and
height to it are going to contain the
same number anyway so global width and
rows
i go here draw a grid given with rows
and
surface so now we're going to put in
well first we're going to put our rows
or
oops width row
and surface like that okay so that
should be working now
in here what we first need to do when
we're drawing a grid
is we want to figure out um how big each
square in the grid is going to be
because what we're going to do is we're
going to just draw lines
going down and across but we need to
figure out where to draw those lines
so we have to figure out kind of like
the gap between each of the lines
so the way we do that i'm just going to
create a variable here size between
is equal to our width integer divided by
our rows
this is just so that we don't get like
large decimal numbers
because that we cannot pass into our uh
drawline
method in uh in python okay so now i'm
just going to create
x variable and a y variable and i'm
going to set these to zero
and say 4l in range
and this is just standing for line
pretty well and rows like that
now what i'm going to do is i'm going to
increment my x by the
size between and i'm going to increment
my y by the same
so y equals y
plus oops size between i can get rid of
one of the spaces here
oh what okay there we are and now we're
simply just going to draw two lines
so to draw a line in pie game all we
have to do is pygame
dot draw dot line and the arguments that
takes is a surface
we need a color in this case it's gonna
be white so we do 255 255 255 for white
we're going to draw at x 0 comma
x w and i'll go through this in just one
second what this does and i'm just going
to copy this and draw one more and then
explain
how this is going to work pretty well
okay so now we need
0 y and
w y like so okay so what this is going
to do is this is going to draw two lines
for us
every loop of this for loop and these
arguments here is the start position of
the line and the end position of the
line so the first line that we want to
draw is going horizontal
which means we don't want to change the
y value at all um so what we need to do
is we need to find the x and then we're
going to
put y at 0 because we're going to be at
the top
i think that's right at least oh sorry
this this line is dropped being drawn
down
not being drawn to the right i was
getting confused there okay so we're
going to change the x
but we're going to keep the y at zero
and then we're going to stay at that
same x and we're going to keep
the y at the width of the screen so that
we're going uh far enough down
and then same thing here this one is
going horizontal excuse me i messed that
up before so our x is always going to
stay at zero
and our y is going to be what's changing
as we draw horizontal lines across the
screen
i hope that makes sense to everyone how
that works anyways i'm going to move on
from that and that's all we need for the
draw grid
uh function so let's just go ahead i
probably made a mistake here but we'll
run the program to see if everything's
working
again our name win is not defined
win.fill ah so i've called this
win one really needs to be surface
like that so let's try now and there we
go we get a nice little grid
um on our screen like so 20 by 20 grid
there we are so now let's move into
another uh function actually let's start
coding on the classes here
so like i was talking about before we're
going to have a snake object which is
going to contain a bunch of cube objects
so essentially what we're going to do is
we're going to have a list of cubes
and that's going to be known as the
snake body so let's go ahead and write
that in now
what i want to do for that is just
create a list so we're just going to say
body
is equal to and then a blank list i'm
also just while we're already up here
and creating a class variable i'm going
to
create turns is equal to and
it's just going to be this set of
squiggly brackets here that we'll uh
we'll get into
in a bit okay so now that we're already
in the snake function
what we need to do is we just need to
define our parameters here that we're
passed in so we're just going to say
self.color
equals color say self.head
equals cube which i'll get into in a
second
given the position say self thought body
dot append our head
self.head like this so what we're doing
here now is we're saying okay so the
head of our snake which is going to be
important because we need to know
where that is at all times so we can
move accordingly is equal to a cube
at the given position and the given
position is what we pass in here
as like the starting position of our
snake or we could create a new snake
like we'd have multiple snakes moving
around and
anyways that's the position now we're
saying we're going to append to the body
this head so now this is in
our list here and then we can go through
that list and we can draw things we can
move it we can check things we want all
of our cubes to be
ordered within this list so that's why
i'm putting that in first
now i'm just going to give this one
which is called during x
is equal to zero and turn y
which is equal to one so what this is
going to do
is we have a direction for x in a
direction for y for moving our snake so
obviously these are going to be
a value like negative 1 1 or
0 and that's going to be the same for y
and x if y or x
is equal to 1 negative 1 then the other
one's going to be equal to 0 because you
can only be moving
in one direction at the same time and
this is just going to keep track of
what direction we're moving in and we'll
use this in the next function that we're
going to code
which is our move function so moving is
pretty straightforward
at least in terms of just if you have
one object moving around the screen
getting it to go left
straight right but when you have the
snake object it has to turn
at certain points so when i click left
um
the rest of the snake is still moving
forward once it reaches the point where
the head turned left
then it has to turn left so that's where
things can get a bit complicated
anyways to start what i'm going to do is
i'm going to say for event
in pi game oops am i doing with my
typing here
pygame dot events dot gets like so
and then we're just gonna say if event
dot
type equals equals pi game
dot quit like this and this is the first
one we always want to code in
because we want to make sure that if
they click that little red arrow it
actually works and we can quit
we're going to do pi game dot quit like
that and i'm just going to say if
actually we don't even need another if
because the way i'm going to do this is
this other way you might have seen in pi
game before to move things around you
said if
uh event dot type equals key down and
then you just check which key was
pressed and move to the left this is a
similar thing but it works
smoother i've used both of them a lot
and this is one i prefer so i'm just
going to use this
so pygame dot pygame.key.get underscore
press
so what this is going to do is it's
going to get a list actually i think
it's like a dictionary or something like
that
that has all the key values and then if
they were pressed or not
so that way if you press more than one
key at once when you're looping through
it'll adjust to that whereas the other
one you can only click one at a time and
you couldn't move like per se diagonally
if you're moving like a character on the
screen it doesn't matter too much for
this but this is the way i like to do it
so now i'm going to say four
key in keys because remember this is
going to give us all of the keys and
then like
one or zero value if they were clicked
or not um so we need to loop through all
of them in check we're going to say if
keys and then pygame dot
key or oops dot k
underscore left i thought it was key
there and
then we're going to say if keys
high game dot okay underscore right like
that
and we can continue down here with up
and down
and then we'll get into exactly what is
going to happen when we click
uh these keys so last one here
all right and there we go okay so now
what we're going to do
is we're going to change the direction
according to
what key we click so if we're going left
that means that our x has to be negative
because the way again coordinates work
in pi game
is in the top left-hand corner of your
screen is 0 0
so if we want to be moving left we
should be making our x
negative to move more towards zero right
if we want to move right now you make
our x positive which would be
one in this case because we're just
going to move one cube at a time to go
further to the right
same thing with the y it's kind of weird
in pi game how the y works because the
more
y you add the further down you go um
so we'll do that inside so for x we're
going to say itself.dern x
equals negative one again because moving
left and we're going to set our turn y
equal to zero and this is because again
we don't wanna be moving in two
directions at once and be going
uh diagonally now this is what i was
talking about
is we need to remember where we actually
turned
because if you just have one cube moving
around that's fine but when we have
multiple cubes we need to be able to
turn left
right we need to remember where we
turned so the tail of our cube can turn
at that point
so that's why we have that self.turns
list up here or just this turns
um i want to say dictionary or set
whatever
so we're going to add to that self.turns
and
we're going to give it a new key and
i'll go through how this works in a
second
self.pause here is equal to
and then we're going to give just a list
of self.
during x and self dot during y
okay so you might be kind of confused on
what's going on here so i've created a
new dictionary up here that's what i'm
going to call it officially you could
think of it as a set as well and pretty
much
we're going to add a key which is the
current position
of the head of our snake
and then it's going to be set equal to
what direction we turned
so we're saying we have a new turn at
this position and
our character or our snake moved left so
it's going to say we have self dot
during y which is right here as negative
one
self dot er surf dot during x array and
then during y is equal to zero so we
know what
way we actually turned and i hope that
makes sense that's uh yeah
that's how we're going to do that now
i'm just going to copy and paste these
and then change these values so when
we're going right this is going to be
one
oops same thing here so we'll
put that in this is going to be zero and
during y we're going up is going to be
negative one
now when we're going down we need to
change this to one
and this to zero and i'm just going to
get rid of that and there we go
okay so that is uh pretty much
how we go about doing this um and i can
also
just put lifts here as well because we
don't want to be able to move in more
than one direction
so we're going to prioritize the left
arrow key if they're not clicking the
left arrow key
then we'll check they're doing the right
otherwise up otherwise down because we
don't want them to be able to click more
than one key at once
okay so next we need to actually move
our
cube and this is where it gets a little
bit more tricky in terms
of looking where our cube is and if it's
at that turn then we're going to turn it
so i'm just going to start coding and
i'm kind of going to go through exactly
what i do
sort for i see and enumerate
oops
and i spoke that wrong didn't they
like that uh and then we're going to say
self.body because we're going to look
through the
list of uh positions that we have in
on the snake we're going to say p equals
c dot position
and i'm just going to copy this um by
the way that's what this little arrow
does here it just makes a copy
so that we're not changing the position
of our snake um
when we do things each just uh just
follow along with it it's not super
important
okay so we're gonna say if p is in self
dot
turns like this because remember what we
did is we added the position
of our head two turns so now we're gonna
say well if
this position is in the turns
then we're going to move or we're going
to turn right
so let's say here so we're going to say
turn
oops equals
self.turns p like that
so now we've seen that it's in there uh
so now it's in there we can find the
index of it uh and we can grab the
direction value so we know what way
we're gonna be moving and now we're just
gonna say c dot move
like this and turn zero
turn one like so okay
now next i'm gonna say if
i equals equals the length of
self.body minus one
oops then i'm gonna do self i don't know
why that's capital
self.turns dot pop
p okay so i know i just did a lot of
coding here and this probably
doesn't make a lot of sense to you guys
so i'm going to kind of run through
exactly what i just did
um it's it's pretty it's a little bit
difficult to explain so anyways
what we start off by doing is we're
going to say we're going to get the
index and we're going to get
the cube object in our self.buddy
because remember
our self.body is made up of cube objects
right here
um that have these properties right
they're going to have a directory in y
direction x
um a start color so on and we're going
to get we're going to get to coding cube
in just a second
so they're cube objects now all of these
cube objects
have a position so i'm saying for each
object here i'm going to grab their
position and i'm going to see if that
position is in our turn list
and we create the turn list and add to
the turn list um
when we turn right when we click left
center right so on
um and then we're going to say okay so
the actual turn so where we're actually
going to be moving
is equal to um that are the
turns list at that index right so we
grab
um the turn direction x and direction y
which we stored there
and now we're just going to say our cube
dot move which is another method that
we're going to code
and we're giving it that direction x in
that direction y so it knows what way it
needs to move
pretty well and then i say if i is equal
to the length of self.body minus one so
that means if we are on the last cube
we're going to remove that turn so once
that last cube
hits that turn we're going to remove it
because if we were just to leave that
turn in the list
that would mean any time you hit that
position on the screen regardless of if
the snake was turning there or not
you'd automatically change directions if
you don't remove it from the list
um i hope that makes sense okay
now also after this if here we're going
to say
if the um what do you call it if it's
not in
the list so if our position is not in
the list we still need to move the snake
because it's constantly moving so what
do we do to this well we write an
else and i'm just going to copy this in
because it's going to take a second to
type because i have another file open
and i'll go through what happened
how this works okay now this looks like
a lot but pretty much what this is doing
for us
is we're checking whether or not we've
reached the edge of the screen
so we're saying if we're moving left and
the position
so the x position of our cube is less
than or equal to zero
um then we're going to change that
position so that it goes to the right
side of the screen
so the way that we can do that is by
saying c dot rows minus one
because again in you start counting at
zero in computers
um so if our rows is like 20 then the
last cube
would be 19 in a list right so c dot
rows minus one and we're gonna be at the
same y value so we'll leave that there
okay and then we say otherwise uh we're
gonna check
if we're going right from moving right
and same thing if we're at the edge of
the screen
move back to the left side by putting
zero here and then next one
if we're going down uh what we're going
to be doing is again
checking are we less than rows minus one
or greater than rows minus one
no we're not or if we are then let's
move us back up to the top of the screen
by changing our y value and then same
thing here if you're moving upwards
now if none of that's true so we're not
at the edge of the screen we're not
moving up left down to whatever i just
said
uh then we're just simply going to move
our cube
at the direction x and the direction y
of that cube already
so if that cube is moving upwards and
it's not turning and it's not going to
the edge of the screen it doesn't need
to be changed
just keep moving it in whatever
direction it's going and that's why i'm
simply referencing the cube's already
existing direction x and direction y
we're not changing anything we're simply
just saying okay let's move you forward
one
like that i hope that makes sense that
was a lot and that's probably one of the
hardest things in this program is
figuring out the movement of the stake
so if you guys understand that um then
that is the hard part kind of over with
and we're going to get into this cube
object so you're going to understand
what all this
means and how our rows and columns kind
of work and stuff like that
okay so i'm just going to forget about
reset and add cue for now because
we'll worry about those later um but
let's get into the uh
draw method because we want to see if
it's actually working and put this on
the screen so simply
for i see
[Music]
numerate why can i not spell enumerate
today like that
uh same thing self.body like that we're
going to say
if i equals equal 0
c dot draw and you'll see why it is in a
second
true else
c dot draw surface
like that okay so the reason i'm doing
this little check here rather than just
drawing every object
is because when we uh draw the first
snake object i'm sure if you remember my
other program it had eyes
so what i would simply want to do is
make sure that when we draw that first
object we add eyes onto it just so we
know where the head of the snake is
uh we don't get confused like what
direction it's moving in although you
shouldn't we i want to add the little
eyes
maybe just for aesthetic as well so what
this true does optional parameter
simply says draw eyes if it's the uh
first one
in our list like that if it's the head
uh and then in this draw method you can
see i have eyes
equals to false but when you make it
equal to true we're going to do a
special thing in here that's going to
draw eyes for us
okay so now that we've coded this this
whole mess
of stuff in the snake class let's just
run the program quickly and see if
anything's happening
so currently we just have the grid we
don't have any errors or anything
but that's because we haven't drawn the
snake object onto the screen yet
so what we need to do is we just need to
simply do s dot draw
it within our redraw window here so i'm
just going to type i'm going to global s
here and i'll global it down there as
well
i'm going to say s dot draw like that
and we need to give it surface so let's
give it a surface and i'm just going to
global s
so that we can reference it there uh and
is there a reason we aren't being
drawn to the screen let's just have a
look quickly
s dot draw let's.draw oh it's because
yes we are indeed drawing s but we
haven't drawn any of the cube objects
yet
and it is calling the draw method on all
of our cube objects which we haven't yet
created hopefully that makes sense but
we'll go ahead and do that now so we
have to code a little bit more before we
can see everything so let's just go
ahead and get into the cube object here
and let's just say self.start equals
start
except i'm actually just going to change
this to position because i believe this
is what it's supposed to be
and then we're going to say self.turn x
equals one self. during y
is equal to zero and self.color
is equal to color and the reason we have
this is because we're going to be
drawing
later what i want to call like a snack
for the uh for the cube to collect for
the snake to collect
um so we want to be able to change the
color with that and
i spelled it wrong like three times
during x and during y
the reason i have duran x here set to
one initially
is because i i want to make sure that we
start moving
in a direction if i had this at zero you
would have to click a key before the
snake starts moving but i want right
when we run the program
for the snake to just start moving so
i'm setting it already with a direction
x and the reason these are optional
again is so that when we create a new
cube object
we don't have to implicitly say
direction x is one direction y is zero
because it's assumed that it's always
going to be like that unless
otherwise stated okay let's have a look
what else do we need to do here
uh we need to now code this move
function which is actually really easy
um all i'm just gonna do is we're gonna
say since we're changing the direction x
in the direction y
in our snake class we need to do that in
here so that it stays with the object
let's say during x equals
during x and then the same thing self
thought
during y equals during y
like that and then we'll go down here
and all we're going to do is we're going
to change our position so self.position
is equal to self.pause 0 which is
our already existing position plus self
thought
during x and they're saying self.
pause one which is our already existing
y value
plus equals self dot during y like that
and just in case i haven't mentioned it
here right we're working with a grid
system
of 20 rows in this instant so when i say
something like
uh if our self-deposition is like 1 3 or
10 10 i'm saying we're in the 10th row
in the 10th column i'm not saying
the x value is equal to 10 and the y
value is equal to 10
because it's not in the case of drawing
on the screen because our screen is
actually a width of 500 pixels
um but just where we are in the grid
which is most important to us right now
um is equal to like that values like one
four or three five um
so on like that just just to make that
clear for anyone who might have been
confused
okay so now for drawing um it's a little
bit harder just because of what i
mentioned as well
is the fact that we need to figure out
the distance between each
x value and each y value so when we're
drawing something in pi game it draws in
the top left hand corner
of the object so if we draw a cube we're
drawing that
in the top left um so we need to figure
out what that x and y value is going to
be for each cube
when we're drawing it to the screen so
i'm just going to call this gap here
that is going to be our distance and
the same thing self.w by self.rows
and we're going to change w and rows
down in our program later but we can
actually just type it in now
like this so 500 and 200 just so we have
that set okay so self.w
answer divided by self.rows again that's
the same thing we did when we were
drawing the grid to figure out the
distance between
our x and y values okay we're going to
say i
is equal to self.pause zero that's going
to save us a bit of typing in our
function here
or in our method i'm just going to say
j.self.pause1
so we're just saying i which stands for
row j stands for column
um like a classic like convention for it
so that we don't have to keep typing
pause zero pause one when we move
okay so the next one next thing we need
to do is now draw a rectangle we're
gonna say pygame.draw.correct
like this and then we need a surface we
need a color so self.color
and then we need a rect and here is a
little bit of math
i'm just going to type it and i'll go
through exactly what what it does
j multiplied by this one
this minus two this s2
okay so the reason i have these little
plus ones and these minus twos here
is just so you can still see the grid
when we draw the rectangle
um because if we were to draw with
exactly the dimensions of
this distance um then what would end up
happening is we'd cover the white lines
of the grid and it just looks kind of
weird if you can't see the white lines
um so that's why i have plus one added
here and minus two just so we're drawn
inside of the uh the circle or inside of
the square a little bit
and you'll see that in a second so what
i'm simply doing is i'm multiplying my i
value
which is going to be my current like row
column by the distance that we need to
get to the next one and then same thing
for j
and then these little add ones minus
twos is just to make sure that we stay
inside
so a quick quick example if you don't
understand is say we're in a position
zero zero so our i is zero and our j is
zero
we're going to say i multiplied by
distance let's say distance is like 40.
okay so zero multiplied by forty
zero zero multiplied by forty 0. so
our position is 0 0 and that's correct
because if we're drawing in the top left
hand corner here and we're in position 0
0 then that's where we should draw again
if you go something like
0 10 and you or and you move down i
guess
so 10 you're moving wide down you're
going to say
0 minus distance 0 and you're going to
say 10 multiplied by distance let's say
it's 40 then we move to that
correct position down the screen so this
is rectangle x y with height
okay makes sense now the next thing we
need to do is we need to draw the eyes
now you can skip this part if you want
i'm just going to copy it in because
it's a little bit of math to make it
them like perfectly aligned on the
square
um but yeah so we say if eyes
and we're saying our center is equal to
distance modulus 2
because that's going to be the center
obviously or much so i'm saying divided
by 2
is going to be the middle of our cube
and we're saying the radius that's how
big the i radius is going to be
and then we go through a little bit of
math here so circle middle is going to
be
high multiplied by distance plus center
minus radius
and then we're finding out the x and
this is just like a random x that i'm
setting
by just putting it 8 pixels up like
every time because i don't want to
calculate the x
i don't feel like doing that and then
i'm drawing two circles based on circle
middle one circle middle two and then
the radius and a color of black
or a color of white actually sir or no
that's black
i'm confused all right anyways with all
that
being said and done and you guys
probably pretty confused right now let's
just run
and see if anything's actually happening
and you can see we have a cube
in the middle of the screen yay so
that's all we've done with all this
coding um
so far it's drawn a cube so actually not
quite because we still
all we have to do now simply to start
having that cube move and seeing our key
presses work
is just do a little bit in the main loop
so let's move down to the main loop now
and have a look here what we need to do
okay
so what i'm going to do is i'm simply
just going to call
s dot move which is our snake object
every time this main loop runs
and what this will allow us to do um is
i want to call this before i read draw
window is it's going to go up to that
method in snake
it's going to check every time that we
run the loop if a key has been pressed
if it has we're going to move
accordingly and remember that in this
move loop here
it moves all of the objects for us so it
moves all those cube objects
and then we're just drawing the grid
we're drawing everything in this redraw
function so it'll just display that and
update that to the screen
so let's see here and we get an error
tuple object is not callable self dot
pause zero plus although they're next
um all right one second guys oh it's
because i've used
okay so apparently i am an idiot and i
forgot to add an equal sign here so the
issue was
simply that this looked something like
this then i changed it to square
brackets
when all i needed to do was put an equal
sign like this and now we should be up
and we're working so to
reiterate the line here that the issue
is out you guys probably saw this when i
coded it to be honest
um is in move in cube it's near the top
of the program
all you have to do is change this add an
equal sign between
this like the bracket and the pause so
now that we run it we can see that we
have a moving
object and that we can move up down left
right etc
so on and so forth like that
okay so play around with that for a
second and now we'll get into
adding cubes and we're actually almost
done we just need to add
the add cube function message box a
little bit in the main loop and then
we'll be finished
okay so what we're going to do now is
that's all great we're moving around but
we need to add stuff to our cube right
like we need to progress the game
so to do this we are going to generate
what i want to call a random snack that
we're going to place on the screen
that our snake can't eat so the way that
we do this
i'm just going to say positions equals
item dot body and this item
oops shouldn't be items should be item
it's just going to be a snake object
i don't know why i'm calling it item but
that's what i'm calling it um and we're
simply just going to set like a new list
equal to that list so on okay
so now we're going to say while true
capital t we're gonna do x equals
random dot rand range if you haven't
imported random yet make sure you do
that
and y equals random dot range range rows
and rows again should be global so let's
make sure
that this works with global rows
like that and then after this we're
going to say if don't know how i just
typed that but the
length of and i'm doing something fancy
here and i'll explain what this does in
a second
okay so i know i just typed uh this
stuff that probably makes absolutely no
sense you guys if you haven't been using
python for a little bit
but pretty much what this is going to do
is we're going to get a list
of a filtered uh list
and we're going to see if any of the
positions
are the same as like the current
position of the snake
pretty well so what we're doing is we're
saying that we want to make sure that
we're not going to put
a snack on top of the snake because if
we have a really long snake the chance
that happens actually
somewhat high and i didn't do this when
i first coded the game so what happened
is when you have your snake moving
around the screen all of a sudden the
snack would pop up
but it's like on the tail of the snake
um which you don't want so what this
is doing and just type it out you don't
really have to understand it
is we're saying this this means a
function uh z
and we're just checking if the z dot
position
uh is equal to uh x y so if it's equal
to x y which is the position we just
generated here by getting two random
numbers so x and y
um then we're going to have to do this
again
so we say continue
and else we break
like that and then i'm just simply going
to return
a tuple or a tubal whatever you want to
call it x y
okay so this is confusing but um you can
do this in like a much longer way with a
for loop where you pretty much
loop through every position in this list
you check it against
x and y you see if it's the same if it's
the same
then do this loop again otherwise you
break and you return x y that's all
we're doing in there uh to generate a
random snap
any message box you're gonna leave that
and in here now
what we're gonna okay so now that i've
created this uh this random snack
function
what i need to do is i need to use it so
i'm just going to create a new object
i'm going to call this snack
and it's going to be equal to another
cube right because we want to have the
same
functionality we want to be able to draw
it possibly move it around right so
we're just going to create a new cube
object we're going to give it a position
of a random snack which is going to be
something like this
random snack and then random snack i
believe oh it takes a row in an item so
what we're going to do is we're going to
give it
or rows and we'll just give it our item
which is gonna be s
um and then after that what else do we
need for cube
i don't think we actually need anything
else i think that's all we need oh i'm
gonna change the color that's what i
wanna do
i'm gonna change the color equal to
green so red green blue 255 for green
so that it shows up and is visible on
screen and now what i'm going to do down
here in this while loop is i'm going to
say
snack i'm going to check if our the head
of our snake
has hit the the snack and if it has
we're gonna add
another part to the body of the snake
otherwise we're not gonna do that right
and then we're gonna generate a new
snack and so on so we're just gonna say
if
s dot body
zero dot pause and this is going to be
the head right because we have it
ordered i don't need those brackets
is equal to snap dot pause and remember
these are both cube objects so this
works fine because they're going to be
tuples
um then what we're going to do is we're
simply going to say s dot
add cube which is a method that we have
there that we haven't actually written
yet
and we're going to say snack is now
equal to well a new cube so i'm just
going to copy this
and paste it here um so all we're doing
is now generating a new cube
for snack i'm sure i could put something
in that like changed
it but this is just the way that works
okay so now that we've done that we
should be able to move around the screen
and get the snack
but we need to code in the add snack
method here which i believe
i have here or add cue so the ad cube is
pretty straightforward
we just have to figure out where we're
adding that snack
or wherever we're adding that cube i
don't know why i keep calling it snack
to
the uh list so what we're going to do is
we're going to figure out where the tail
is
and we want to add it after that tail so
tail
is equal to self dot body negative one
the last element in that list i'm going
to say dx dy which again is going to be
our direction x direction why i'm just
shorting it
shorting it here it's going to be tail
dot dern x
and tail dot turn y
like this now again you can do this in
two lines i'm just doing it like this
because it's faster
and now i'm going to copy some again and
we'll just go through exactly what this
does
okay so pretty much this looks
complicated
but all it's going to be doing is
checking what direction that we're
currently moving in like the head of the
cube or the tail actually of the cube is
moving in
so that we can then make sure that when
we add that um
cube we know where to add it so for
adding it like to the right of the cube
to the left of the cube above it below
it
and we can give it the correct direction
to be moving in
so pretty much um what we do here
is we just say we're going to append a
new cube to our body
and its position if we're moving to the
right which in here we are because dx
equals 1
is one less than the x position of
that tail so whatever the last cube is
one less than that
and that's so that we don't add a cube
per se to the right when we're moving to
the right and then
we're just gonna have overlapping cubes
and you're not gonna see them right
same thing down here if we're moving
down that means
or not down sorry for moving left that
means we need to add the cube
to the right side um so one plus that
tail of
the exposition of the tail of the cube
or of the snake sorry so that we can um
have it in the proper position right and
the same thing here with x and y
uh or with y so that when we're moving
up or
we're moving down then we add it above
otherwise we move
we put it below so i just stumbled
through that um because there was a lot
of different words they're very similar
anyways
what we need to do now is simply set the
direction
uh for that cube so now that we added it
in if we just left it like that it
wouldn't be moving
anywhere so we just need to change that
to the current direction of that
tail so whatever the tail is moving
that's where this new cube is going to
be moving in that direction so we're
just going to say
self.body negative1.dern
x equals dx and then same thing down
here except we're going to change these
to y
during y equals d y and that again is
just the
uh where our tail is moving at that
current moment
okay so now that we've got all that done
it's time to see what syntax
air we get next name rows is parameter
and global
one second so i've actually never even
ran into that error oh global rows as
okay so let's just make this r and let's
change this
to be
one second ah we can just get rid of
this and this should work there we go
so now we move around like this the only
issue is our snack
is not being generated on the screen and
i don't know why
that is exactly happening oh it's
because we're not drawing the snack
that's why so now i'm just going to
global snack up here i believe that's
what i called it
and i'm simply just going to say snack
dot
draw like that and i gotta give it a
surface
so let's give it a surface let's run and
error name snack is not defined it's
because i didn't global it down here so
let's
go over that okay so now we have the
snack
it's on the screen and you can see that
when we collect it we have that cube
added to the end of our snake
and that pretty much is almost the game
done so all we need to do now
is write that reset method and then we
need to just
simply check like when we lose like
right now the snake can go through each
other right
through itself and you can see we have a
huge error when the snake
can go through itself so we need to make
sure that when we hit ourselves
um we like end the game and we need to
write that message
method as well so to do this um
again i'm just going to copy in this for
loop
uh and then we'll kind of go go from
there so
let's move in here okay so for x and
range the
length of s dot body uh we're going to
say s dot body x which is going to be
we're just looping through every cube in
our snake body
we're checking if the position is in a
list
of um all the positions
after that works um that's how we're
checking the collision if you want to do
it your own way
um go ahead but this is the way that i
like to do it okay so now what i'm going
to do
um is i just want to print to the
console like their score uh just so that
i know what it is let's say a score
oops
and then we'll just say plus is the
length of
s dot body but this is going to have to
be converted to a string unless i put a
comma like that so let's just do it like
that
and then i am going to simply display a
message box will say message box
like this message underscore box uh we
have a subject
and we have content and we'll we'll do
that in just a second because i haven't
yet um actually coded that
and then we're going to reset our snake
by just doing s dot reset and this is
going to take a position which is going
to be our starting position again 10 10.
um and then we're going to break out of
this for loop because if we collided
once we don't really care if we collided
again
and go back and we continue the game
with a snake
that has length one now okay
so our reset um this is pretty
straightforward all i'm doing in this
reset
is i'm just gonna get rid of our turns
i'm gonna get rid of
our body um and i'm just going to change
like the direction x and the direction y
so maybe it's faster if i just copy it
and you guys can just copy this out
so pretty much all i'm doing is i'm
setting a new head um which is going to
be equal to
again like whatever position we give in
because we can move it at a different
position if we wanted to
i'm clearing self.body which is in the
class variable here
and then i'm adding head i'm setting
turns equal to blank
direction x is zero direction y is set
to one again so we start moving
and you can see it's pretty much exactly
what i have typed out here except i'm
just resetting the turns list
okay so now that we've done that all we
need to code is message box
so this one's pretty easy um you can see
up here
just in case you haven't looked yet um i
import tkinter stk and then from
decanter i import message box
now this is how you create a message box
in a pie game and this is how you create
one that actually shows up on top of the
screen
um and that doesn't like float kind of
below it or it doesn't
show up right away if you want to say
that um so just watch this is extremely
useful to use in other programs too if
you
if you copy out this uh function and
then you just drag it into other ones so
attributes
topmost comma true what this simply does
is we're creating a root oops which is
not
root.tk it's root equal to tk.tk which
is going to be a new tkinter window
we're making sure that this window is
going to be on top of anything
so if we have like a bunch of different
windows open it just comes up on top
which is what we want
i'm just going to simply make this
window now invisible
and i'll explain how this works in a
second and then from this message box
um what do you call it method class
whatever it's going to say message box
dot show info
and then we're going to do subject and
content
and this just takes it takes a few more
parameters as well if you want but
pretty much just just shows info
given whatever subject we type in and
whatever content we have and now i'm
going to say
try root dot
destroy like that
accept oops uh
pass and don't ask me what this does
because honestly i don't know but it
just works
so pretty much it shows this message box
and i'm actually pretty sure
the way that this works is it constantly
keeps trying to destroy
the message box until eventually you
click the x button and then it actually
can
i think it's like something like that so
anyways that's how you create a message
box
and with that we all need to do is add a
subject and content so i'm going to say
you lost
and our message will be play
again let's run the program for the last
time
and make sure everything is working so
there we go i just need to get my snake
to a length that is uh
large enough to the point where i can
actually hit myself
oh okay and there we go so pretty much
we ran into an error
what is the air i spelt attributes wrong
that is lovely air to run into
let's run back up here
attributes attributes attributes where
did i even make this function i must
have scrolled path it all right there we
go
and i believe that's correct let's try
this now
so i'm actually just going to go and see
if i can there we go okay
so we get a message says you lost play
again and the reason i died there by the
way
is because while i was moving right i
moved left so technically
um the head of my snake actually ran
into another part of it so it says you
lost
play again um and you can make that say
exactly what you want and then we can
see that our guy just continues to move
so on
so anyways if you guys want to see more
content like this
go check out my channel it is named tech
with tim and i do have a bunch of videos
teaching stuff like pie game
and doing a bunch of python tutorials
you guys will definitely learn a lot
following through some of my videos
and i would be very grateful if you guys
went over there and liked some of my
videos and subscribed